bonjour à tous place dans un instant à
l'audition de viktor mayer schoenberger
de l'oxford internet institute
ce chercheur spécialisé dans l'économie
du numérique a enseigné aussi bien à
oxford qu'à l'université d'harvard aux
états unis il a été auditionné par la
mission commune d'information sur la
gouvernance mondiale d'internet
une mission qui est présidé par le
sénateur socialiste gaëtan gorce et dont
la rapporteure et la sénatrice centriste
catherine morin desailly cette mission
s'intéresse plus particulièrement à la
place de l'europe dans cette gouvernance
mondiale d'internet
l'europe qui est plutôt en retard en la
matière en matière d'organisation de
coordination du numérique par rapport
aux géants américains tout de suite donc
retour à cette audition qui s'est tenu
mi février salle clemenceau la radio
c'est internet et beaucoup d'autres
choses encore karl architecture de
l'internet permet ces innovations qui
sont à la pointe de la technologie et à
la lutte pour l'utilisateur
donc c'était le premier point que je
voulais vous dire l'internet n'est pas
neutre deuxièmement sur cinq un deuxième
point dans les états unis le
gouvernement américain actuellement a le
contrôle sur certains éléments
essentiels de l'internet notamment sur
les noms et les adresses des études des
ordinateurs alors c'est une organisation
qui gère tout cela qui gère tout cela
donc au nom de gouvernement de
gouvernante anonyme en quelque sorte
mais ce n'est pas cacher le fait que si
quelqu'un et on pense notamment aux
états unis
cela fait que le gouvernement se trouve
dans une situation très puissante et je
pense que il faut noter que les
tentatives des gouvernements américains
de transmettre de déléguer certaines
activités à d'autres organisations ces
tentatives ont échoué
le fait de laisser une majorité de
nations avoir le contrôle plein contrôle
de toutes les communications
cela ferait que cela pourrait tomber
vulnérables à la censure en plus mais
alors que des centaines de noms millions
de personnes notamment dans les pays
nous nous tenons occidentaux se joignent
se connectent à l'internet il y a de
plus en plus de pression pour que il ya
une gouvernance qui est quelque sorte en
quelque forme de l'internet ensuite
l'internet par lui même va à l'encontre
des tentatives de contraindre à
l'internet
le fait de relier l'internet hd pouvoir
de contrôle ou de liberté de l'internet
au fond la gouvernance il faut voir si
cela va dans le sens d'un contrôle qui
va limiter les pouvoirs
cette idée d'une constitution d'une
gouvernance de gouvernance de l'internet
déjà été proposée maintenant une part
les pays le pays les états unis qui très
souvent sermonne les autres pays
non en fait c'est l'union européenne qui
ai fait une proposition de constitution
de création d'une forme de gouvernance
et cela sur la base d'une initiative
française salon les etats unis se sont
mis du côté de la russie
in qui voudrait contrôler davantage
l'internet moi j'applaudis votre
perspicacité
lorsque vous avez proposé cette idée
plein d'innovations et très utile si les
états unis ici avait fait ce qu'ils
avaient fait en 1789 à savoir suivre
qu'avaient fait les français dans le
domaine des libertés pour tous
on aurait peut-être aujourd'hui une
gouvernance robuste de l'internet et
quelques problèmes les plus urgents de
gouvernance d'internet serait peut-être
un peu moins urgent un peu moins
pressants non malheureusement
la proposition de l'union européenne n'a
pas été adopté il ya 10 ans mais
peut-être peut-être que cette idée
pourrait être remise au goût du jour et
on devrait peut-être le faire je pense
que cela mérite réflexion
ensuite les caractères de ces
changements au niveau d'internet et ce
dont il faut se protéger
et bien quand on pense à l'internet en
pense aux gens qui communiquent entre
eux mais les formes de communication par
voix par échanges de données cela va
jouer un rôle de plus en plus petit car
les flux de données entre ordinateurs
vont se développer aujourd'hui le
téléphone intelligent à partir des
applications en voit énormément de
données sur sa situation et aussi sur
les îles et les différents forme de
paquets de données qui sont envoyées
sous toutes ses formes et c'est une
tendance qui ne fera que s'accélérer
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs plus de 100
millions d'utilisateurs 100 millions
d'utilisateurs dans le monde utilisent
une application de téléphones
intelligents qui leur dit qu'elle est la
meilleure route à prendre pour aller au
travail pour éviter les embouteillages
mais très peu de ces 100 millions
d'utilisateurs de cette application
savent en fait eux ce sont les personnes
censure en quelque sorte de ce système
et les données qu'ils génèrent eh bien
ces données sont réemployés à d'autres
but lucratif et puis on les caméras que
vous avez des appareils photos que vous
avez ici dans le téléphone c'est
tellement bien que les appareils photos
peuvent calculer le pouls de quelqu'un à
distance car avec chaque battement de
coeur la couleur du front change les
errements cet invisible à l'oeil nu mais
l'appareil photo lui il le voit toutes
ces données ne sont pas forcément des
données personnelles et donc des données
et en temps en affaires pour lesquelles
on a des informations
prenez ce qui se passe au niveau des
sondés automobile
on peut mesurer le niveau de bruit
vibrations des voitures et à travers
l'analyse de ces données de masse à
l'avenir on va pour prédire avec
beaucoup de précision qu'une certaine
partie pièces de votre voiture va tomber
en panne avant qu'elle tombe en panne
de cette manière les pièces pourront
être échangées modifier juste avant la
panne ce qui va permettre de réduire le
nombre d'accidents le moins et d'avoir
moins d'embouteillages sur la route
l'idée de base ici c'est que les données
on off une usine valeur et le fait
d'utiliser les damnés les données une
seule fois à un seul objectif cela
nécessiterait pas tout le potentiel de
l'information on veut garder les
informations et les utiliser
de très nombreuses fois les données
c'est le nouvel or d'aujourd'hui est
donc il ya la ruée vers les informations
comme en live la ruée vers l'or dont la
question d'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas de
savoir qui peut communiquer avec gilles
mais qui peut utiliser internet pour
recueillir
maximum de données qui peut contrôler et
maîtriser ces données et qui peut-on
tirer le maximum de bénéfices
économiques nous devons veiller à ce que
les informations restent quelque chose
qui est utilisé pour l' avantage le
bénéfice de la société et pour les
particules les mécanismes d'aujourd'hui
que ce soit des droits de propriété de
chacun des brevets à tout cela ne répond
absolument pas à ce nouveau pouvoir des
données et le fait qu'il faut gouverner
cela de façon responsable en deuxième
par don cinquième point c'est que nous
devons parler de nouveaux défis qui se
trouvent encore à trois ou cinq années
de demandes mais cette fille qui minent
actuellement les fondements de notre
société de notre démocratie
c'est ce que l'on appelle la dictature
des informations hélas le fait que l'on
lui attachent plus d'informations 20
qu'importante aux données elles n'ont
pas s'il possède par exemple les données
ne peuvent pas tout montrer mais on a su
on suppose que les de l'est peuvent
expliquer les causes de tel ou tel fait
c'est normal nous sommes des êtres
humains
on veut savoir quel sera l'avion veut
réduire les risques on veut réduire les
incertitudes et on veut peut-être
certainement d'ailleurs réduire ces
risques
les données circulent sur l'internet et
cela combiné à l'analyse des données de
masse nous donne des prévisions
probabiliste sur l'avenir qui semble
très précise et donc on sera tenté de
réagir non au comportement mais une
prévision une prédiction
on sera donc tenté de punir des
personnes et de les tenir responsables
nom de ce qu'ils ont
fait mais de ce qui est proposé par un
algorithme et donc nous serons aussi
tenté d'abuser de ses données de masse
et de tomber dans les pièges de ces
données de masse mais si on fait cela on
va se nier le libre arbitre de chacun on
va abolir la responsabilité de chacun
car si on est unis à cause d'une
prédiction avant d'agir pour qu'elle
résout s2j faudrait vous vous triez
obéir à la loi et qu'elle en serait donc
la place de la culpabilité humaine sans
culpabilité
il n'ira jamais d'innocence humaine et
tonnes de riz agir maintenant pour
protéger une autre liberté humaine de
contenir d'imposer des contraintes sur
les analyses des données de masse pour
faire en sorte que ces analyses ne soit
pas un abus de notre liberté on peut le
faire on peut créer une liste de liberté
on peut travailler sur la codification
jeu de tout cela et tout cela et est à
la hauteur de la grande tradition de la
france par le domaine des libertés mais
il faut faire vite que ce sont ces garde
fous en classe le danger c'est que la
société civile les êtres humains c'est
toi il ne sera plus les maîtres de
l'infrastructure qui est en train de se
créer
ces données de masse et nous allons tous
devenir des objets économique
donc je vous encourage vivement mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs d'être à
l'auteur de ce défi pour que les données
de masse puisse être utilisé en toute
humilité et pour le bien de l'humanité
je vous remercie merci pour cette
présentation à la fois très détaillée en
même temps plein de conviction je vais
laisser à 1 catherine morin desailly le
soin de vous poser les premières
questions et puis nous pour ensuite
développer notre échange
merci monsieur le président merci de
cette présentation qui finalement donne
un peu froid dans le dos c'est un
scénario qu'on a vu apparaître dans le
film minority report que vous commentez
tout à fait de façon pertinente alors
pour éviter justement ces dérives
cette mauvaise utilisation finalement de
deux données qui collecter analyser
peuvent au contraire produire des ex des
effets extrêmement positif
très concrètement comment voyez-vous une
gouvernance mondiale avec le rôle corée
a joué notre pays l'europe dans cette
gouvernance se se dessiner quand on fait
le point un petit peu sur ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui donc des discussions
sont en cours
la sphère snowdown a ébranlé les
consciences en tout cas en europe n'est
pas seulement
y at il là une opportunité selon vous de
pouvoir rééquilibrer un certain nombre
de choses et 2 et 2 et de fonctionnement
et puis je voulais aller un tout petit
peu loin dans la prospective parce que
vous avez évoqué des scénarios quant à
l'utilisation des données vous avez dit
que nous allons tous devenir des objets
économique en tout cas nous serons des
des êtres humains connectés je ne sais
pas si vous connaissez les travaux de
joël de rosnay qui a bien expliqué que
aujourd'hui la la connexion entre
l'informatique et la biologie pouvait
potentiellement donner naissance à des
nouveaux êtres qui dominerait qui
dominerait le monde alors on est
peut-être dans la la science fiction
mais finalement d'après ce que vous
dites on n'est pas si loin que ça dont
je voulais votre point de vue sur sur ça
je ferai de mon mieux et je serrais
d'être très précis je vais commencer par
votre première question et de façon
concrète qu'est ce que la france qu'est
ce que l'union européenne peut faire
et est-ce qu'on est au seuil d'un
nouveau chapitre d'une belle opportunité
oui je pense qu'on a une belle
opportunité devant nous car justement la
sphère snowdon a fait comprendre à
beaucoup de personnes
deux points essentiels à savoir
qu'actuellement les états unis détient
beaucoup de pouvoir sur les flux de
données
alors c'est ce qu'a permis à washington
avec leurs services secrets donc de
capter de recueillir tellement de flux
de courriels et d'information qui est en
ligne
l'europe à mon sens doit comprendre que
la gouvernance de l'internet peut être
et devrait être plus équilibré et je
pense que les utilisateurs comprennent
tout à fait cette approche il y a
tellement d'utilisateurs en europe qui
changent de fournisseur de services de
mail google microsoft pour passer un des
fournisseurs européens la suisse
proposent leurs services disant que
c'est l'équivalent d'un compte en banque
suisse pour protéger donc les courriels
il y a donc des occasions a saisi en
cours les sociétés européennes et nous
voyons que les sociétés d'internet aux
états unis souffre souffre en fait
beaucoup des retombées de la sphère
snowdon sinon elle ne réagirait pas avec
le temps de véhémence par rapport au
gouvernement américain pour qu'il dise
quelles sont les informations auxquelles
les naissains accède donc je pense qu'il
opportunités économiques et aussi une
belle opportunité démocratique et tout à
fait unique est aussi une autre
opportunité
sachez que il y a cinq ans les seules
possibilités de partage d'informations
de mes étudiants s'étaient utiliser
facebook est au ruc et utiliser facebook
aujourd'hui ils ont des douzaines
d'alternatives qui sont disponibles vous
avez snap chat qui est une application
sur l'iphone et sur android used to send
qui permet d'envoyer une photographie
d'une personne à l'autre et puis la
photo est détruite automatiquement en
l'espace de quelques secondes
il y aquelques il ya une semaine 350
millions 350 millions de photos étaient
partagés de cette façon donc 350
millions de photos de moi sur facebook
ce qui veut dire que ces fournisseurs
d'accès à l'internet ressentent bien la
pression qui est exercée par le
consommateur qui souhaite mieux protéger
sa vie personnelle
je pense que nous autres européens nous
avons une opportunité économique pour se
prévaloir de ces nouveaux services et à
travers notre puissance économique à
travers l'argent que l'on veut que l'on
peut dépenser on peut démontrer aux
américains que l'on veut davantage de
protection de notre vie privée du
microsoft a déclaré qu'aujourd'hui ils
veulent bien garantir que les données
européennes ne sont stockés que sur les
serveurs européens c'est une indication
de la direction de ce changement de
direction que ces grandes sociétés
peuvent prendre le virage quelques
prendre si elles sont convaincus que
c'est ce que veulent les clients et donc
je pense que c'est vraiment moment pour
l'europe de jouer cette carte économique
je suis tout à fait convaincu que cette
approche pragmatique est très très utile
je m'arrête là parce que vous avez
peut-être une question précise sur ce
que je viens de dire sinon je poursuis
avec ma réponse matin
concernant concernant justement le droit
à l'oubli que vous venez d'évoquer son
importance vous avez des propositions
très concrètes à ce sujet qui est décidé
à chaque données personnelles transmises
une date de péremption à travers un tag
électronique
comment se construit le système à partir
de ça quelques élans rôle l'état
pourrait à jouer là dedans il y
aurait-il une loi pour encadrer un tel
système avez vous réfléchi un petit peu
à l'application et la façon de mettre en
oeuvre très concrètement ces
propositions thank you madame oui merci
madame rapporteur d'avoir dirigé notre
pensée vers ce qui est dit à bruxelles
sur le droit à l'oubli
il faut savoir que le droit d'être
oubliés samarienne de nouveau le droit
d'être oublié 7
ça fait partie des lois sur la
protection de données en france et dans
tous les pays de l'union européenne
depuis des décennies une directive de
l'union européenne sur la protection de
vivriers privée et des données précise
que chaque personne a le droit de
reprendre sans une accord concernant le
traitement des données donc on a déjà le
droit d'être oublié ce qu'a fait la
commission européenne c'est de renommée
de changer de nom quelque chose qui
existait déjà mais on avait déjà ce
droit le vrai problème en fait c'est que
on avait cette faculté
ce droit mais on n'a pas fait
suffisamment pour faire appliquer ce
droit on n'a pas rendu efficace cette
loi et ce droit dont nous jouissons donc
plutôt que de réfléchir et de penser
concevoir de nouvelles lois je pense
qu'il faut travailler pour faire en
sorte que les lois qui existent soit
plus efficace et je pense que l'un des
problèmes auxquels l'europe est
confrontée aujourd'hui que c'est que de
leur bon nombre des fournisseurs
d'internet son domicile dans de petits
pays tels que l'irlande qui n'ont pas de
cadre réglementaire très efficaces ce
qui ne permet pas de mettre en oeuvre de
façon efficace la protection de la
personne les données je pense qu'il faut
avoir un cadre véritablement européen de
la protection de personnes des données
et c'est vraiment au coeur des débats à
bruxelles aujourd'hui je pense j'espère
que nous aurons une véritable
proposition dans ce sens qui va émaner
du parlement et qui sera votée ce sera
vraiment un premier pas essentiel mais
ce ne sera pas suffisant
ce ne sera pas suffisant car comme je
les dis les données de masse inhérents
aux données de masse c'est la
réutilisation de ces données donc le
fait de demander à la personne au moment
où les données sont collectées s'ils
sont d'accord ou non cette absurde dans
un monde où on ne sait pas à ce moment
là à quelles fins je vais utiliser les
données par la suite et donc moi je
pense que nous devons ajouter quelque
chose au cadre réglementaire concernant
la protection de données à des personnes
hélas il s'agit de la responsabilité de
ceux qui traitent ces grands volumes de
données
ce n'est pas suffisant de compter sur
les particuliers de porter plainte
contre les ai failli c'est david contre
goliath
et à la différence de david de la bible
les individus n'ont pas suffisamment de
pouvoir est long il n'exerçait pas
suffisement il faut renforcer le cadre
réglementaire et ce qui est très
intéressant
c'est que beaucoup de grandes
entreprises très responsable le
demandent également en quarts e.on se
distinguer par rapport à ces dispose de
marché gris les entreprises que nous ne
font pas attention qui ne respectent pas
les lois européennes qui existe et je
pense donc que après avoir fait en sorte
que les lois européennes soient
modifiées il faut penser très rapidement
la nouvelle génération de protection de
données pour faire en sorte que en et
des lois qui correspondent aux problèmes
de données de masse vous venez insisté
sur la nécessité de réglementer ce droit
à l'oubli en tout cas la maîtrise de la
protection des données dans un cadre
européen vous avez bien insister là
dessus je soulignerai vous êtes titanic
et que justement lendemain de la sphère
snowdown alors qu'un règlement intérieur
et est en cours de discussion pour
pouvoir aboutir le plus rapidement
possible il ya eu des positions
divergences parmi les les états membres
dont principalement les les britanniques
une autre question que je voulais vous
poser si vous accorder beaucoup
d'importance à la protection des
individus dans l'analyse de la maîtrise
de de ce que doit être la maîtrise de
ses données d'aucuns disent que
justement le projet de règlement n'était
pas assez équilibrée
parce qu'il faut voir aussi que les
données c'est du potentiel de croissance
et c'est de l'emploi et donc il faut
veiller à ce que les entreprises
puissent disposer de façon assez facile
également de tout ce ce potentiel
comment se trouve cet équilibre non la
vision que vous avez vous même tout à
fait sauf que je suis autrichien madame
je ne suis pas britannique et donc mes
racines se trouvent dans les grandes
traditions du continent européen
je ne suis pas d'accord avec la position
officielle qui avait été adoptée par
londres concernant la protection de
données de la vie privée et je suis tout
à fait opposé d'ailleurs la position
britannique
je pense que nous devons trouver un
équilibre pragmatique et voilà ce que je
proposerai si on fait en sorte que les
entreprises qui traitent les données de
chacun soient directement responsable
donc avant d'utiliser les données un de
nouveaux objectifs ces entreprises
devraient passer par une évaluation très
complète des risques encourus pour les
particuliers et on se fondant sur cette
analyse
les entreprises devraient mettre en
place des garde-fous pour réduit lé côté
une est faste de l'utilisation de cette
nouvelle utilisation des données et au
bout du compte les entreprises auraient
une responsabilité juridique pour leurs
actions ce qui ferait qu il y aurait une
vraie responsabilité juridique elle je
ne pense pas uniquement aux droits
civils mais au droit criminel pénale
également on a rarement vu des
directeurs qui ont été tenus pour
pénalement responsables de leurs actions
mais il faudrait vraiment que
la protection des données de chacun
devienne une question de premier plan
plutôt que d'être une question de
quelques centaines de milliers d'euros
d'amendé infligée à telle ou telle
société et donc je pense que l'on
pourrait créer un cadre juridique qui
créerait donc ce niveau de
responsabilité très élevé on retour les
entreprises aux le droit de réutiliser
les données sans être vidés de revenir
vers le particulier pour lui redemander
son consentement
fovu selon l'entreprise passe par ce
processus d' analyse et c'est conforme à
la loi
je serai d'ailleurs plus facile à faire
un exemple google a pu prédire avec
beaucoup de succès le développement des
épidémies de grippe alors fait est
possible car google a réutilisé remanié
en quelque sorte réanalyser les requêtes
qui était fait sur internet par des
centaines de millions d'utilisateurs
d'internet
alors on peut pas revenir vers ses
millions d'utilisateurs y mais je pense
qu'avec un nouveau régime juridique
ça pourrait être possible légalement et
cela pourrait être très bénéfique pour
la société dans son ensemble et cela
permettrait de protéger les libertés
individuelles est plus importante
merci ce que vous décrivez là ressemble
d'ailleurs beaucoup à la législation
française en matière de protection des
données traitement des données
personnelles puisque il faut une
autorisation ça doit être
proportionnelle et finalités doivent
être considérées comme légitimes tous
ces dispositifs existent mais s'applique
à les traitements qui concerne soit une
petite entreprise sous l'administration
moi j'aurais par rapport à cela de
plusieurs questions la première concerne
la possibilité de faire respecter une
telle législation
dans la mesure où elle suppose
évidemment un consensus et des outils
juridiques
or aujourd'hui le rapport entre les
états et déséquilibré il y a déjà des
accords entre l'union européenne et les
etats-unis notamment loi comme ses
phares bord et on voit bien la
difficulté pour une européenne de
vérifier que ces préoccupations soient
réellement prises en compte et que les
engagements pris sont respectées
d'autant qu'ils étaient unis où une
conception du droit qui s'applique aux
citoyens américains ça nous a été
rappelé très récemment c'est une
première difficulté est ce que on peut
imaginer
et ce qui est imaginable que des outils
juridiques efficace se met en place
la deuxième observation c est ce qu on
ne risque pas en faisant cela de mettre
en place un mouvement qui va susciter
une opposition extrêmement forte
puisqu'elle va aller à l'opposé de
l'intérêt de ces grandes entreprises qui
évidemment d'utiliser avec le maximum de
liberté le maximum de données puisque
c'est là qu'est la richesse troisième
question enfin est ce que cette bataille
vaut la peine tant que et ça renvoie un
peu à la première que je vous pose est
temps que ces entreprises sont pour
l'essentiel américaine droit américain
est ce que l'europe ne serait pas plus à
l'aise entre guillemets pour faire
valoir ses principes si elle les
appliquer les entreprises européennes
autrement dit est-ce que l'enjeu
économique n'est pas plus important que
l'enjeu juridique j'ajoute puisque vous
choisi allusion à la capacité de
prédictibilité de google qui serait
intéressant de savoir ce que google
prédit aujourd'hui quant à l'évolution
du droit sur internet au regard de
l'ensemble des requêtes qui peut
analyser castaing caf est oui merci
infiniment
comment tout d'abord où quel serait le
rôle de l'europe étant donné
la situation prédominante des états unis
et le fait consultation ni son point de
vue juridique est différent de celui de
l'europe
alors je pense que la question est
restée assez simple n'oublions pas que
les sociétés internet veulent faire des
bénéfices et 30 à 40% de leurs bénéfices
se trouvent en europe elles ont des
filiales en europe elles doivent se
conformer au droit européen
donc ce n'est pas le fait que l'on
puisse faire en sorte que le
gouvernement américain soit d'accord
avec ce claudine mais tout simplement
les entreprises américaines qui veulent
travailler en europe devront se
conformer aux lois européennes et les
sociétés américaines facebook n'ont
jamais dit le contraire
facebook par exemple a toujours dit
qu'elle veut se conformer à la loi
européenne notamment en irlande où elle
est basée ce qui veut dire que dans le
contexte européenne
on peut aider les plus petits pays à
devenir régulateurs plus efficace
peut-être permettre de centraliser la
surveillance réglementaire
je pense que la loi qui est proposé 20
peu plus dans ce sens et si j'ai bien
compris la position française a toujours
été très positive dans ce sens
votre deuxième question concerne les
sociétés les entreprises alors c'est
très intéressant car cette approche de
responsabilité dont j'ai parlé c'est une
approche qui fait suite un processus de
discussions entre des centaines
d'experts en donner et aussi avec les
grands entreprises microsoft ibm hp et
cui fax toutes les grandes entreprises
elles ont une belle réputation
internationale à protéger et à préserver
elle veut donc trouver des solutions
pour lui qu'elle connaît ses objectifs
donc je pense que les grandes
entreprises internationales c'est pas
les nuits ce sont des alliés potentiels
sans rapports des sociétés qui n'opère
que aux états unis il en existe mais je
pense que si vous faites en sorte que
les cinq ou six plus grosses entreprises
sur internet se mettre d'accord sur une
certaine approche je pense que l'on peut
couvrir 80% du terrain serait pas
parfait mais ce serait quand même un
très bon début est votre troisième
question c'est est ce que l'on peut
faire quelque chose pour combattre la
domination de l'innovation qui provient
des sociétés américaines sachez que les
données de masse c'est fascinant car les
données ne favorise pas en fait la
position dominante dominante d'une
grande entreprise parfois une petite
donc les petites start-up qui
travaillent dans l'analyse de données
peuvent remporter un grand succès on a
déjà vu cela
très souvent aux états unis et donc même
si on arrive avec une petite guerre de
retard
si on a une pme on peut gagner si on a
la bonne idée et si on peut faire en
sorte que cette bonne idée puisse être
mise en pratique ce que l'on doit faire
en europe
pour faciliter tout cela et on devrait
faciliter tout cela c'est de considérer
se dire que les données c'est dans
l'infrastructure
c'est une source d' avantages
économiques
c'est quelque chose qui contribue au
développement de nouveaux secteurs à
tous les pays européens ont aujourd'hui
des problèmes budgétaires donc je fait
de donner de l'argent à une société
c'est difficile mais tonicité des aides
sous forme de données pour que ces
données soient disponibles non seulement
aux entreprises mais aussi au public
cela peut jouer un rôle crucial en
facilitant cette croissance des
entreprises start up et pour le coup il
ya une pauvreté ce que disent certains
en tout cas une contradiction entre
cette volonté de protéger les données
telles que souhaite le faire les
européens de manière plus stricte c'est
à dire d'avoir une vision assez
protectrice de la vie privée une manière
plus large que le font les les
américains les pays anglo-saxons et
cette volonté de développer l'ucsd zone
est au service d'un projet économique de
développement économique
non non non pas du tout bonne partie des
données qui sont intéressantes pour les
entreprises n'ont aucune valeur
personnelle ou dans une mesure très très
limité pensez aux données concernant les
vibrations dans les voitures les
vibrations du moteur
c'est très très intéressant et utile
pour les constructeurs automobiles
mais ça vraiment un intérêt très limité
pour un particulier et à travers une
nouvelle forme de protection de données
en europe on ne serait pas en train de
protéger davantage mais de mieux
protéger ce qui veut dire qu'on pourrait
protéger la dignité et l'existence et
l'identité de la personne c'est ça qui
est important
une mais en même temps on pourrait
permettre l'utilisation des données de
nouvelles failles prévoir certaines
choses ce n'est pas une dichotomie il
n'y a rien de de simpliste ici il faut
veiller à ce que la protection des
données soit efficace mais ne soient pas
utilisés ou ne devienne pas un fardeau
artificielle qui pèserait sur
l'innovation et on a vu ceci très
souvent avec les réseaux sociaux par
exemple facebook
ce n'était pas le premier réseau social
c'était des sites heures amérique pardon
européens qui étaient les premiers le
e-commerce a pris son essor il ya quinze
ans sans problème
on n'aura pas les obstacles c'était pas
la protection des données
les obstacles c'était des questions de
fiscalité etc
donc je ne pense pas que la protection
de données soit vraiment une contre
importante je pense que un régime de
protection de données et prévisible qui
instaure un climat de confiance de la
part des particuliers qui donc souhaite
veuille bien apporter ou mettra
disponibilité leurs données personnelles
je pense que c'est ça qu'il faut viser
questions complémentaires qui concerne à
la fois la valeur que représentent les
données et les questions fiscales en
france nous avons dans les mois qui
viennent de s'écouler procéder à une
réflexion sur l'optimisation fiscale que
pratiquent les gérants américains qui
bénéficient de cette valeur ajoutée des
des services qui se sont créés dans le
monde de l'internet et la réflexion à
apporter sur ce qui était vous
représentez réelle valeur et pour être
en quelque sorte constitué quelque chose
de palpable en l'occurrence les les
données est ce que des réflexions
semblables ont été conduites dans votre
entourage est ce que vous avez eu vendre
deux de ses connaissances de ces
propositions est qu'en pensez vous
ilyas absolue clair oui oui en effet je
pense que c'est un problème ce n'est pas
un problème qui a été créée par internet
en fait les entreprises internationales
ont toujours cherché à minimiser leur
fardeau fiscal non seulement en europe
mais aux états unis est également aussi
vous voyez le menton qui paie par apport
en termes d'impôts au gouvernement
américain vous serez très choqués qu'un
rat leurs bases fiscales est à
l'extérieur des états unis et de
l'europe
je pense que l'internet
kate a vraiment cacher une partie des
flux de valeur et donc ç'a permis cette
optimisation fiscale nous devait créer
des systèmes plus transparent nous ne
devons pas créer davantage de
bureaucratie tout lui-même je pense j'ai
l'impression que l'union européenne
travaille sur une approche plus
transparents et je pense que d'ailleurs
washington voudrait se rapprocher de
bruxelles et washington ne bénéficie pas
non plus des impôts au niveau d'apple se
trouvent surtout dans des îles offshore
etc et donc je pense qu'on peut faire
quelque chose mais ici comme ailleurs la
clé n'est pas de suivre les données mais
de suivre la piste de l'argent c'est ça
qui est essentiel
peut-être pour élargir un petit peu le
sujet de la la gouvernance pourriez-vous
nous nous exposer votre point de vue
notamment suite à la faire signer aux
dames et des révélations et qu'elle a
suscité de l'émotion qu'elle a provoqué
notamment en europe mais pas seulement
chez nos amis brésiliens
comment voyez vous l'évolution de cette
gouvernance mondiale bien sûr quel rôle
l'europe peut-elle y avoir à jouer mais
dans ce rééquilibrage que beaucoup
appellent de leurs voeux
comment voyez vous les choses
s'organisent et à la veille de cette
conférence de sao paulo
je ne sais pas si vous même vous vous
rendrez en tout cas nombre de
spécialistes chercheront à en être pour
réfléchir justement à peut-être la
redéfinition d'une gouvernance qui ceux
qui se cherchent avez vous un point de
vue particulier sur sur la question je
ne pense pas que la conférence de sao
paulo change quoi que ce soit je suis
désolé de vous détruire vos rêves de et
vos attentes à ce sujet mais il faut
savoir que sao paulo et ailleurs il y a
le processus du site
et oui cette s'éteint en fait un groupe
d'experts qui existent parfois
autoproclamés qui avancent l'idée
d'avoir de multiples partenaires qui
sort est la base de tout c'est à dire
que tous les partenaires toutes les
parties prenantes participerait au débat
sur la gouvernance de l'internet
en fait c'est du théâtre
tout cela rien de plus les vraies
décisions sont prises ailleurs mais où
sont-elles prises ces décisions et
comment en fait après
la personne washington s'est trouvé sous
pression sous beaucoup de pression
l'internationalisation qui est demandé
par la chine et par cela réussit en
allant vers lité us et pas vraiment
souhaitée par les etats-unis
mais il ya une coalition derrière les
etats-unis qui s'oppose à ce que l'it et
hugues guide to décide de tout dans le
monde cette coalition se réduit petit à
petit et donc tôt ou tard les états unis
vont se trouver face à la réalité à
savoir que ils devront trouver tout de
même une forme ou une autre
d'internationalisation afin de calmer
les esprits et afin de répondre à cette
pression internationale à long terme
regardez tout simplement la croissance
de population
vous savez l'internet ne restera plus
l'apanage du monde occidental est donc
ce que l'on devra faire la meilleure
chose à faire c'est d'insérer d'intégrer
dans l'internet aujourd'hui ton que l'on
peut le faire les valeurs qui nous sont
chères et c'est ce que je voulais dire
quand je parlais de la création de
constitution de la gouvernance
d'internet pour qu'on est incertaine
éléments de cette internationalisation
mais cette internationalisation sa
limite est bordée par des valeurs des
valeurs de liberté d'expression
d'association les valeurs qui sont nés
de la révolution française de 1789 et
les états unis en rejeter ceux ci
l'administration bush avait rejeté cette
idée il ya plus de dix ans mais
peut-être dans un contexte heck
changé peut-être washington serait plus
ouvert l'idée car qu'est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres comme alternatif en fait sur la
table il n'y a pas grande chose et donc
je vraiment j'encourage l'europe à
ouvrir les communications avec les états
unis réclament lire la communication et
le fait d'avoir les internationalisation
et qui comporte qui intègre des valeurs
je pense que ce c'est rien et même chose
pour les états unis aujourd'hui la
démarche américaine soit très largement
déterminé mais c'est une appréciation
très très péjorative par des
préoccupations de sécurité donc de
captation d'information et que les etats
unis soient moins 100 et notamment avec
l'idéologie autour de la lutte contre le
terrorisme vous ne pensez pas qu'il ya
entre guillemets l'inde élément qui va
bloquer cette évolution énorme savez
j'ai critiqué j'ai beaucoup critiqué les
états unis au cours de ces dernières
heures mais n'oublions pas qu'il est
facile de critiquer les états unis alors
que l'europe n'a pas les mains blanches
non plus les services secrets
britanniques eu beaucoup d'information
personnelle également et d'autres pays y
compris mon petit pays l'autriche
aimerait beaucoup avoir plus de données
à recueillir s'ils pouvaient seulement
le faire s'il avait seulement l'argent
pour le faire et donc sur le plan moral
les européens ne sont pas mieux placé
vraiment que les américains tout
simplement les européens en plus de
contraintes pratiques concrets et il ya
peut-être eu des contraintes
constitutionnelles et également qui
limite les actions des européens je
pense qu'il a presque une majorité
d'américains qui souhaitent davantage de
protection de la vie privée fait que
et démocrates libéraux et les
républicains de droit
ce sont des ensembles aux états unis
pour essayer d'empêcher que les
naissains recueille ces informations et
à quelques côtes près au congrès ils ont
failli faire voter cette loi
c'était inédit ce par quoi est ce que ça
se fait parce que deux des deux bords
politiques c'est à chaque extrémité on
peut comprendre qu'il y a vraiment un
malaise très profond dans la population
américaine
si on demande aux américains aujourd'hui
s'il voudrait avoir ce droit à l'oubli
nine est bien à peu près 90% des
américains dirais oui
90% des américains et donc c'est 91%
ceux qui ont elles sont âgées de plus de
60 ans ou mais pour ceux qui sont âgés
de moins de 24 ans le chiffre se
trouvent autour de 80% et donc ça c'est
des voix pour les élections futures
et ça représente également des alliés
pour les européens merci beaucoup avant
de nous quitter je vais vérifier s'il
n'y a pas d'autres d'autres questions
la dernière question alors s'il n'y en a
pas d'autre si vous voulez vous beaucoup
les données personnelles et la vie
privée ce qu'on était encore capable
justement alors d'internet de donner une
définition qui soit juridiquement
satisfaisante ils garantissent une
protection de ce qu'est la vie privée
beaucoup de ceux qui défendent
aujourd'hui le développement d'internet
à juste raison sur l'aspect du processus
nous disent qu'ils impliquent
nécessairement ne serait ce que par le
comportement des utilisateurs une autre
définition une définition moins
restrictive et qu'elle va s'imposer à
nous d'une certaine manière quel est
votre sentiment sur ce point et si vous
le voulez bien on conclura sur ce sujet
ce qui me permettra de vous renouveler
mais mes remerciements pour nous avoir
rendu visite
je pense que nous devons quitter ce
droit qui tape négatif
le droit de se protéger d'être
tranquille la vie privée et bien c'est
une question de participation pas
comment on participe à un verre de
l'internet mais comment on y participe
et certains utilisateurs savent exercer
ce 3e même mais pour beaucoup de
personnes c'est trop compliqué à l'étude
sur facebook
allez sur les paramètres de vie privée
et vous ne comprenez plus rien et dans
beaucoup de domaines y compris celui ci
le gouvernement doit prendre des mesures
en ce qui concerne la sécurité
automobile par exemple la sécurité
routière la sécurité alimentaire nous
avons des régulateurs qui ont décidé
pour nous ce qui doit être fait et bien
c'est la même chose pour internet seront
désormais aussi beaucoup merci de cette
contribution à notre discussion j'ai
bien noté que vous restiez disponibles
comme la vie tout à l'heure juste avant
notre échange donc on a bien noté cette
disponibilité ou vous en remercier dieu
voilà pour cette audition de viktor
mayer schoenberger de l'oxford internet
institute qui a donc été auditionnée par
la mission commune d'information sur la
gouvernance mondiale d'internet mission
qui s'intéresse plus particulièrement à
la place de l'europe dans cette
gouvernance mondiale nous pouvons bien
sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
parlementaire cet après midi et on
restera sur le même thème sur la
gouvernance mondiale d'internet très
bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires